since halloween is tomorrow there's  extra emphasis on keeping our little  ghosts and goblins safe while they  trick-or-treat today umc children's  hospital hosted its annual halloween  safe tacular event kids got some goodies  but families also got a lot of  information about staying safe tonight  and tomorrow  people are ready to be out and engage in  a safe environment it is so important  because as halloween is approaching we  need to teach families how to do it in a  safe way  metro and clark county police were there  along with firefighters a big emphasis  today was pedestrian safety in making  sure everyone stays aware on our local  roads